one minute for each player play commences now
defending he's slow actual dog water take
attacking
can you guys take me off can
you take me off choice.com
can you take me off the website
take me off the website get me off
i could still win i could still win
okay
is he doing what
jesus
i had too much time to think
30 seconds all raw reactions
oh my god oh my god what is he doing
oh god thank you
what
mr beast
are they not are they not switching it off i was
hoping i had good timing my the only thing i got
going for me is timing you're supposed to switch
off why we there's no timing if it's still on me
just saw comments you're my man cuts like an
ad or something i get i don't have anything now
hey guys um
make sure to twitch prime or something tonight i
hope you're all having a good day
today have you checked your balls